the NBA is in town so I thought what
better way to welcome to UK but they
give him a little lesson and have a cook
the most amazing steak so we're here at
the Savoy Hotel in London and I've set
up Sean and qur'an with to the finest
chefs in the business
little do they know that I only give
some feedback
I've got someone to help me today and
this guy knows how to cook trust me my
dear friend Jamie Redknapp ready I'll
try my best so you know I have to be
very careful cuz we're six foot one six
foot two yeah they're into the seventh
yeah I've not really got your back in
this one guys Wow baby it's a lot of
work yeah oh it is hey listen to chat
more the whisking I think yeah so now we
need to get the steak on okay and when I
season it a little bit of salt let's get
on let's go baby
oh no no rush you don't want to rush
this is style right surprise a little
going on there don't be scared of it now
it won't bite judge you don't want to
know how aggressive he is right he is a
face that was a todo competitor you
played against Kobe Bryant got a little
copper you know he's gonna look hope you
know all of us are maybe shy
jockey you copy over there no no super
confident go back face it basis train
train get in the pan not in the
my hand burn this is high we don't over
here okay guys so now we're in the
restaurant 130 years old this place I
mean it's seen some famous faces along
the way got any ideas guys who just the
guest judge could be old enjoy Austin
Powers
the surprise is over guys here he is
first of all I could smell those steaks
two miles down the road I'll just flown
all the way in from the US to taste
these steaks
oh my we grew up with a love of great
stays because both our mums are great
cooks and I love I see moms who's got
the best steak come on we both care for
you so like I mean like let's get it you
ready for Thursday oh I'm excited to see
what they're gonna do I was in Miami
last week and I watch the witches play
against the heat they pointed good right
now yeah that's a good young players but
I visualize not overcooked just look at
that it looks appetizing lights all the
Bears yeah the moment of truth because
I'm gonna go right into the middle and
it should be nice and caramelized on the
outside and pink in the middle that it's
pink in the middle
beautiful use olive oil yeah you finish
your butter yep sure lots garlic thyme
he's happy look at that face
that's a great start yeah right there
that's that's the three-pointer
Jamie Oh pink like Oh Lord it's not
overdone is incredibly juicy please help
yourself it's a lab we'd like some bread
give us 30 seconds please Bobby decide
and which one either I don't know who
that is but I lady that's your steak
that's my steak
agreed yes
we do have a winner because it was one
steak that is slightly better seasoned
all around the outstanding steak by a
narrow narrow narrow margin this one you
guys are bought huge excitement in UK
and the audience now it's just getting
bigger and bigger the game is just
taking off globally you know and I've
been I've been fortunate to travel with
multiple countries and when I say the
fan base for MBA is amazing I think a
lot of people gonna be excited about the
pace of the game and these two young
teams you talk about Bradley bill when
you talk about some Hardaway and these
guys with the New York Knicks this is
gonna be a fun game to watch youth
that's on the rise with no sillens yeah
the game is back in the u.s. it's
totally dominated by the home side
supporting Thursday night's game is
gonna neutral
oh yeah why do you think that'll have an
effect on class so you have the fan base
that's excited to see NBA basketball on
the soil so everybody would be cheering
and just enjoying it but obviously if I
mature a little harder for the team
that's in front that's what I think this
golden says he's become so big now
especially in the football community so
you'll see a lot of famous soccer
players in and around the arena it's
exciting news for UK so long may that
continue yes it's not they can always be
chefs like you